oui maxime et vous vous êtes les rois
des scoops mais dans ces conditions il
n'y a jamais eu deux gars qui ne sortait
autant de scoop que vous et bien
aujourd'hui on va faire une bataille de
scoop vous avez écouté tout dire que des
scoops médias si vous vous allez aussi
réagir est ce que vous préférez les
scoops de thierry où les scoops de
maxime
vous allez avoir trois coupes chacun
l'un après l'autre d'accord c'est la
battle de scoop mais juste avant on a
demandé aux gens si vous leur aviez
manqué regarder sur twitter la question
thierry moreau vous at il manqué
regardez la réponse qui va arriver dans
quelques heures
vous at il manqué lui à 70% alors à
quand ce trois coupes on va démarrer par
vous puisque thierry
il a cependant invité non justement il
rit on dit alors vous vous avez un truc
médias défis alors j'en ai 3 je suis
interne et d'ailleurs comment alors le
problème soulevé la sauce le premier
j'ai fait l'interview de caroline got la
patronne de france 2 pour médias plus
elle est revenue sur la sphère texte on
l'apprend trois choses dans l'interview
que 1 l
france 2 et la prod ont eu un mal fou à
ce que tex s'excuse publiquement suite à
sa blague graveleuse deuxième
information
ça fait des mois qu'ils lui demandent de
changer son animation unsa manière
d'animer ce qui n'est absolument pas
fait les troisième bol troisième chose
car les gold a dit le public féminin à
un énorme problème avec textes et ses
blagues que le public juste déplacer et
louvre
en gros pour elle n'y a pas de levée de
boucliers juste on confond son métier
d'animateur et son métier de comédien à
l'oral alors ça scénario qu'on a lu
partout pour recycler les trucs vous
fais ta gueule on m'a dit que ce serait
sympa de le citer
juste et il est très frais ouais et on
s'est pas présentée du coup il est
mignon n'hésitez pas quelque 8 à l'heure
et en plus si les idées ça va tomber
comme qui dirait il est célibataire
c'est une première mais encore les
plastiques au charme et aux saveurs de
l'orient ce soir je la laisse sur le
banc que ça oui mais kelly c'est trop
simple à être ce serait trop évident on
fait vrai c'est vrai ce serait choquant
la mère qui regardent le scoop de maxis
mecheri donc texte équipe qui plaisait
pas aux femmes c'est pour ça qu'il a été
viré de france 2 apparemment c'était la
vraie raison c'est ça je vous dise qu'on
retient de votre info est ce que vous y
croyez j'ai bien aimé moi il est allé à
la source
il a bien explosé son truc c'est vrai
c'est vrai un bon ce qu ils avaient tous
dit croyez ce que signifie la direction
dit que le texte ne plaisait pas aux
femmes qui demandent s'il ya une étude
qui a été faite au long cours et un
papier intitulé résultats officiels
convoi alors thierry moreau votre scoop
du premier scoop une nouvelle émission
qui arrive sur tf1 bientôt en pré access
dans à 18 heures non oui avec karine
ferri à la présentation à et sur les
mariages encore démaria évidemment ils
vont rebondir sur le succès de quatre
mariages et une lune de miel
donc ce sera un peu dans la même veine
ce sera pas produit par par dechavanne
on sait pas je sais pas qui va produire
mais ça va arriver d'ici quelques
semaines sur tf1
si vous donnez votre point de vue à
garder la cire émission de karine ferri
saint mathieu honnêtement kanye west et
madame si je l'avais déjà entendu
thierry aux maximes maxim nucci tiller
pas photo thierry thierry bas et vous
maxxo pasqua laxou bas c'est normal
bon alors c'est qui qui gagnent le
premier point thierry vautherot deuxième
secousse 14% 14% c'est un chiffre que
vous ne connaissiez pas d'ailleurs c'est
l'augmentation de fréquentation des
sites internet de tous les annonceurs
qui font de la pub dans tpm paix avant
pendant et après non c'est une société
qui s'appelle adnot tv café cette étude
ils ont regardé ils ont analysé d'autres
toc qui sont derrière et les annonceurs
voit une augmentation immédiate de
fréquentation de leurs sites internet de
14%
lorsqu'ils sont regardés pendant 14 %
d'augmentation j'en appelle à la chaîne
ouais donc les amis c'est tout je ne
savais pas du tout il sait que le savez
pression ne le fait pas
maxime votre secours qui très grosse
info télé v 2010 bien décrocher le
premier rôle
ouais féminin d'un film à bout claude
junior de sociétés juniors
une comédie qui s'appelle les dégâts qui
sera tourné en février
et ça c'est quand même pas mal il fait
un carton sur le net les dégâts et c'est
vrai que kelly vient de décrocher un
rôle dans le cnra voilà ils vont
traverser
les coupes slim
si maxime j'ai trop hâte de voir matthew
merci c'était facile mais j'ai dit oui
maxime oui maxime encore bon petit é oui
j'ai dit oui maxime week-end et maxime
c'est donc maxime qui gagnent le
deuxième et le troisième est là mais ce
coup à jouer maintenant à nous ou eux à
nouveau jeu télé débarque bientôt en
france the tale 2 chaises je vous
explique sets 6 2 6 1 c'est le château
chef de quatre candidats qui ne se
connaissent pas vont former une équipe
pour essayer de vaincre un champion de
la culture générale la notion de la
production a fait appel à des génies de
la culture g un pilote a été tourné en
allemagne a importé phare présentée par
christophe dechavanne et un autre par
olivier minne pour france 2 non
socialiste a d'abord bien sûr le jeu est
beau jeu les très très bon alors moi et
moi je les ai vus plusieurs fois passé
ce jeu et personne ne l'a pris pendant
17 ans cette blonde c'est toujours
mauvais signe à jeudi mais c'est comme
les mecs quand il tourne trop fait pas
bon il y passe avec vous jean michel mr
ses créditeurs il ne reviendra pas d'un
groupe tf1 il a priori la chaîne a pris
la décision de ne pas remettre enfin
tout simplement parce que le entre le
coup parce que c'est très cher comme
problème c'est vrai que plusieurs
millions d'euros et l'audience est ce
que ça rapporte en cubes et endemol ne
veut pas laisser tomber la marque donc
ils cherchent actuellement à refourguer
le concept sur les autres personnes le
programme ça sera compliqué la seule
chez nous ça serait pertinence rénergie
12 mais c'est beaucoup trop cher
exactement de toute façon je pense que
oui alors et l'a2 bon scoop est alors de
basculer sur les allées très vite qu'ils
aillent chéries chéris agathine pour ce
jeu que j'ai maxime parce que cette
série non non il est vrai qu'il y ait
des sur ses douces et pas vous merci moi
égalité s'il faut vraiment choisir un
maxime oui alors là c'est thierry
l'affairé ce qui titille maxime chéri
mon petit coeur écoutez alors on raye
alibert je crois qu'il ya égalité
non il y à égalité égalité c'est kelly
qui va décider au niveau des chronos
daou
on est vraiment vraiment honnête oui
maxxo je suis honnête je dis la vérité j
aime beaucoup magzine c'est le scoop que
sécrète souris ne reviendra pas je
décide de mettre deux points thierry
terrain glissant
je suis
non mais franchement parce que the chase
est très bien mais si les crêtes story
ne reverra pas c'est un vrai scoop sud
est aurait alors notre sondage twitter
pour savoir qui a donné à bath et chair
et en os à 69 % mais maxime vous avez
été très bon quand même six coupes très
bon si ça pouvait être comme ça tous les
dégâts pour le monde ce serait
exceptionnel